el lunes por la mañana había 12 pulgadas
de nieve sobre el suelo la temperatura
subió y para el martes en la mañana se
habían derretido 2 pulgadas 2 pulgadas
más se derritieron para el miércoles de
la mañana este patrón continuo durante
toda la semana hasta que la nieve
desapareció básicamente no están
diciendo que el lunes en la mañana había
12 pulgadas de nieve y cada día se
fueron perdiendo 2 pulgadas el martes
había 10 pulgadas el miércoles había 8
pulgadas y este patrón continuo y lo que
nos piden es elabora una ecuación y una
gráfica que muestre la relación entre el
día y la cantidad de nieve sobre el
suelo definamos entonces una variable
que nos indique cuántos días han pasado
desde el lunes así que sea
o sea x igual a días
después días después
del lunes
y sea que sea igual
pulgadas
pulgadas de nieve sobre el suelo
pulgadas de nieve sobre el suelo una
manera de ver esto es
y el número de pulgadas de nieve va a
ser el primer día tuvimos 12 pulgadas
cuando x era igual a 0 lunes había 12
pulgadas y cada día se pierden 2
pulgadas es decir hay que restarle 2 por
el número de días así el martes ha
pasado un día entonces hay 12 menos 2
por 1 10 pulgadas el miércoles han
pasado dos días hay 12 menos 2 por 28
pulgadas y así sucesivamente así es que
esta es la ecuación que relaciona el
número de pulgadas de nieve con el
número de días x es el número de días
que han transcurrido después del lunes y
que es el número de pulgadas de nieve
sobre el suelo empezamos con 12 y cada
día se derritieron exactamente 2
pulgadas
ahora ratificamos esta ecuación
construyamos nuestros ejes este es mi
eje vertical y que son pulgadas y es
igual a pulgadas de nieve pongamos de
igual a pulgadas nieve mientras que x
el eje x déjame bajar un poco el eje x
representa días días después del lunes
días después lunes aquí tendríamos 0
días aquí tendríamos uno dos tres cuatro
cinco seis días después del lunes y a
los 0 días después del lunes es decir el
mero lunes teníamos 12 pulgadas de nieve
sobre el suelo vamos a ponerlo por aquí
este punto indica 12 pulgadas de nieve
sobre el suelo el lunes
de hecho hagamos una tabla para que sea
más fácil graficar los puntos entonces
tenemos nuestra tablet son los valores
de x ideye x el número de días serían 0
1 2 3 4 5 6 días después del lunes
ahora para allí empezamos con 12
pulgadas el día 0 el mero lunes tenemos
12 pulgadas y perdemos 2 pulgadas cada
día el martes y hay 10 luego 8
420 graphic hemos los puntos ya hemos
graficado el 012 graphic hemos ahora el
110 voy a hacer con otro color el 1,10
aquí tenemos el 10 para la yesería el
punto 1,10
luego el punto 2,8 el punto 2 aquí
tenemos el 2 aquí tendríamos el 8 para
la aie
este es el 8 para la y luego tenemos el
punto 3,6 el punto 3,6 aquí ubicamos el
punto 3 6-3 para la x 6 para la y
observamos que ya podemos ver a través
de estos puntos cómo se está formando
una recta posteriormente tenemos el
punto 4,4 en el día 4 tenemos 4 pulgadas
de nieve sobre el suelo tenemos aquí
entonces el punto 44
luego el punto 5 252 lo tenemos aquí
este es el 2 para la 10 y finalmente
seis días después del lunes es decir el
domingo ya no hay nieve sobre el piso
ubicamos entonces el punto 6,0 y podemos
ver así la línea que se forma
representando a la ecuación que es una
relación lineal quedó un poco curva por
como puse los puntos pero es en realidad
una línea recta ya hemos hecho lo que
nos pedían una ecuación que refleja que
al principio había 12 pulgadas de nieve
y se perdían 2 pulgadas cada día y
también construimos la gráfica de la
ecuación